lessons that you get at CIA is that
there's a strong connection and
empirical connection between childhood
trauma and high achievement the science
is out there that I've looked it up on
my own the connection is extraordinary
that people who experience
the right amount of childhood trauma the
right amount being enough that you had
to prove something but not so much that
you had to adopt external coping
mechanisms right well wealth like drugs
correct drugs addictions to pornography
like there's a certain amount of trauma
that's the right amount of trauma that
turns you into this High achiever you
always have to win something because
you're trying to win favor when
attention win rewards win Glory wins
something so you're always achieving
you're always driving yourself towards
something but it's not because you were
born with Thrive it's because some part
of your childhood those formative years
taught you that by achieving you will be
rewarded